en 1945 le général de gaulle leur avait
accordé le droit de vote c'était déjà un
grand pas pour plus d'égalité avec les
hommes
mais il fallut attendre plus de vingt
ans pour gagner une autre révolution et
elle revendique la contraception libre
et gratuite et la liberté de
l'avortement
le combat pour le contrôle des
naissances menée par le député lucien
neuwirth surnommé le père la pilule
aboutissent à une loi sur la libération
de la contraception
mais les débats sur le sujet reste
mémorable les opposants s'acharne les
hommes perdront alors la fière
conscience de leur virilité féconde et
les femmes ne seront plus qu'un objet de
volupté stérile les députés avaient
plaidé lui même la cause des femmes
auprès du général de gaulle limogé
n'roll à la libération où j'ai donné
droit de vote aux femmes
vous avez eu raison il avait bien gagné
pendant la résistance avait bien fait de
leur donner seront mieux maintenant les
temps sont venus d'ordonner le droit de
maîtriser leur fécondité parce que c'est
leur fécondité aujourd'hui 2 millions de
femmes utilisent ce contraceptif
mais l'église l'interdît toujours en
1968 le woman libre mouvement de
libération des femmes qui a vu le jour
aux états unis fait des émules en france
elle défile monte sur les barricades
elle réclame le remboursement de la
pilule par la sécurité sociale et le
droit à l'avortement
la pilule est en vente libre et les
centres de planning familial se sont
multipliées mais l'avortement est
toujours passible des assises et même de
la peine de mort
les militantes féministes de 1971
réclamant toute priorité une sexualité
heureuse et des charges et des angoisses
en problèmes matériels et elle
revendique la contraception libre et
gratuite et la liberté de l'avortement
et le procès de bobigny reste exemplaire
cette jeune fille de 15 ans jugée pour
avortement est acquitté pour la soutenir
343 femmes avaient publiquement avoué
s'être fait avorter
il faudra attendre 1975 et la ténacité
d'une femme simone veil pour que
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
fasse l'objet d'une loi
et qu'en définitive à la porte en propre
sur le plan de la justice pour les
femmes et à mesure elle met fin à une
situation que tout le monde qu'on dit
fier est notamment présent dans la copie
de décembre 1983 loi sur l'égalité
professionnelle
à travail égal salaire égal pour les
hommes et les femmes année après année
les bastions réservé aux hommes tombent
polytechnique and chopinet l'académie
française
marguerite yourcenar la cour de
cassation simone rozès
mais pour les femmes rien n'est gagné à
travail égal il faut payer parfois 10 %
de moins que les hommes en 1998 aucune
femme n'est à la tête des 200 premières
entreprises françaises en politique elle
reste encore assez peu nombreuses
on a même essayé d'instituer des quotas
en 1974 françois giroux dirigeait le
premier secrétariat d'état à la
condition féminine en 91
edith cresson passe à matignon sur fond
de misogynie pourtant selon un sondage
récent les français seraient maintenant
prêts à élire une femme à la tête du
pays